did you know that when you put your cash
into a savings account at a bank you're
actually loaning the bank money and
whatever you do a loan there's two
things you want to know How likely is it
that I'm gonna get my money back and how
much am I getting paid for the risk
that's the interest rate and so banks
will pay you nothing basically on the
risk for the money because most people
feel confident that the banks are going
to be able to give them their money back
the problem is history doesn't say that
banks have gone bankrupt many times in
the past by getting greedy and in a
period that it was over leveraged and
lots of free money there's lots of
Institutions that were massively over
leveraged and we will probably see that
in the next however many months and so
the easiest way that you can combat
against that is a different vehicle it's
called t-bills or treasuries from the
government and you can buy treasuries so
that you can guarantee that you're going
to get your money back because they can
always print it and you get four percent
per year on the money so rather than
risking the money in a riskier vehicle
that pays you less anybody can go by
treasury bond and use it as their
figurative bank account where they store
their money because if you're not going
to do anything with the money you might
as well let it sit there before you
figure out what you're going to do next